Samsung has been offering wireless
earbuds for a while now
even before the earpods but they never
really took off the battery life was
horrible they had some connection issues
and then the price well about a month
ago they fixed all of that and for our
one-month review of the Galaxy buds I'll
have to say that they're great and for
many they're actually better than the
air pods now don't get me wrong
air pods are excellent but there are a
few ways the galaxy pods simply do it
better the first and most important
thing is the price you're paying 130
dollars compared to 200 for the air pods
- and that could be a deal-breaker for a
lot of people Samsung had to price these
competitively and they did they're
mainly marketed to Android users but
some iPhone users may even choose to buy
these over-the-air pods - so we tested
the Galaxy buds with an iPhone and made
a video on it to see if they're worth it
for iPhone users of course they're a lot
better with an Android phone because you
can download the dedicated Galaxy buds
app which I'll get into in just a minute
back to the air pots - you could say 40
dollars by not getting the wireless
charging case but the Galaxy buds have
that feature included for the same price
and the great thing is that Samsung's
s10 line of smartphones all support
reverse and wireless charging so you can
charge these without a cable
realistically you won't always use this
but it's nice to know that it's there
just in case you need it another great
thing about the galaxy bus is that they
seal in your ears so while they don't
have active noise cancellation they
still pluck out a good amount of
background noise the air paws feature an
open design so you still hear everything
in the background and when you turn the
volume up people all around you can more
easily hear what you're listening to if
you're using the galaxy buds with
Android you'll have the ambient aware
mode and can tweak the sound profile
this is missing on iOS but the default
settings sounded best to us
Samsung also added the Apple like
automatic sync setup but it's not as
simple because of all the permission
requests you have to accept the seal
design of the Galaxy buds gives you a
lot more privacy and it also makes them
sound louder than the speakers actually
are since all the sound is sealed into
your ear and can't escape this greatly
increases bass reproduction and it
actually helps them save battery life
since the speakers themselves aren't as
loud
they're also splash and sweat resistant
just make sure not to get any water into
the speaker grille on the inside another
thing I like about the Galaxy buds is
just how subtle they are they sit flush
in your ears with nothing hanging out or
wrapping around your ear and it's
actually quite impressive how will they
fit and stay in your ears and I
absolutely love that Samsung Desai
not to put their logo on the face of the
buds so they look really clean each bud
has a touch surface that you could
customize and overall it works quite
well you can even change bixie out for
google assistant they come with a
charging case that's a bit larger
overall than the earpods and it has less
battery life seven hours of additional
juice instead of round 19 now that's a
big difference on paper but not as big
in the real world unless you use them
all day long for most you can plug them
in to charge for an hour every three to
four days or so and you'll be fine for
the buzz themselves Samsung rates the
Galaxy buds at around six hours while
Apple rates the air pots at five take a
look at the sound guys truly wireless
test the Galaxy buds are leading the
pack with six and a half hours while the
air pots come in at just over four hours
that's a lot of positives for the Galaxy
buds so what are the downsides the
biggest one for consumers is the volume
for most quality content they are loud
enough because of the seal and the sound
quality is great for the price but I
really wish they were louder the air
pots can get loud too loud actually but
that comes in handy when the podcast or
video you're listening to is too quiet
with the air pods you have more Headroom
to compensate but in cases like this the
Galaxy buds can be a little hard to use
my other complaints is the mic quality
it's usable but doesn't sound great
here's a comparison this is a microphone
quality test with the Galaxy buds this
is a microphone quality tests with the
air pods to the air pots mic is closer
and pointed at your mouth so you can get
much better mic quality instead of
having the mic flush with your head
which makes it harder to pick up your
speech another limitation compared to
the new air pods is no hands-free access
to your virtual assistant this isn't a
big deal for me personally but let me
know if it is for you down in the
comment section below overall just like
with sm+ and s10 II I'm really impressed
with the Galaxy buds now they're not
perfect but considering the sound
quality convenience features and price
they are an excellent value even if
you're an iPhone user this have been
Mac's with Mac stack if you want to see
more videos like this one click that
little circle above and check out our
galaxy buds for iPhone users video we're
right over here thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next one